ثلاث اصدقائي اللي استشهدوا في رياضه
البار محمود ابو شرخ وعبد الله حسان
ومحمود نسمان الله يرحمهم جم كان احلامهم
زي احلام انه نفسهم يشاركوا في محافل
دوليه ونفسهم يشاركوا في البطولات
لكن الله
يرحمه اسمي امير الغرباوي انا لاعب باكر
ونازح من الصفطاوي رفح كنت بدرس لغه
الماني وبكمل لغات فرنسي وانجليزي وحتى
اطلع كنت يعني من غزه والبسطه مشروع يعني
لحتى اكمل حياتك كهان كناجح لكن اللي
بيبسط اكثر لما انزل اوري الاطفال
النازحين في المكان ه في الخيام نوريهم
رياضه الباركور ايش هي بالنسبه لي
وبالنسبه لهم كيف بتعبر عن سعادته وسعادته
انت من متى بتلعب باركو تقريبا من 12
سنه
واح
ا الاطفال دائما نفسهم يصيروا زينا يعني
دائما انا كل كلمه بسمعها من اي طفل
بشوفني بلعب بقول نفسي اصير زيك كنت احلم
كثير اني اشارك في محافل دوليه لكن لما
كبرت ادركت انه ما بينفع لاني من غزه بس
انا من الشباب اللي لعبت على الركام بس
لما لعبنا على الركام لعبناها لنوصل رساله
للناس انه احنا قد ما صار فينا من تهجير
وقصف لانه احنا مكملين في هذه الرياضه على
الركان بيوتنا ثلاث اصدقاء اللي استشهدوا
في رياضه البار محمود ابو شرخ وعبد الله
حسان ومحمود نسمان الله يرحمهم جمي كان
احلامهم زي احلام انه نفسهم يشاركوا في
محافل دوليه ونفسهم يشاركوا في البطولات
لكن الله يرحمه بيتنا ان قصح للاسف يعني
ايش اكثر شيء عزز
عليككم كثير شغلات البيت نفسه عز علي
ذكرياتي كلها فييه ومن يوم ما انولدت وانا
فيه ف واغراضي كلها في اوعي الباركور كان
فرق باركور تبعت لي اواعي ففيها كمان
ذكرياتي وكتبه حتى الدراسه فيه كتب اللغه
ف عز علي كل شيء كنت منزل ستوري تو ان
مشتاق للحاره وض فبفكر فيه بس لما
سالتيني خطر في بالك خطر في
بالك ترجع على ايش رح
تعمل انت مصره تخلين
اهي فان مش حابب ارجع اشوف الحاره ركام
بدي اخر نظره تكون سليم
بس
نرجع ان شاء
الله بعمرها باذن الله راح كل اولاد
الحاره افرحهم باذن الله واعملهم فعاليه
كله وع روكان بيت باذن الله واحد اين
[موسيقى]
لا
ه